and the mental picture that I use is
kind of inking water you know I come
from China where you know calligraphy
and painting etc that's sort of part of
the culture so when ink meets the water
right the pattern as in sort of nature
the fractals is different every time
just like our life but the to quickly
become completely inseparable right and
so our practice our spiritual practice
in this example is the ink and
everything else we do our work our
family our relationships is the water
and so the spiritual life makes
everything more rich without was my
experiences it took home a different
quality I became different I showed that
different boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Solomon we are on-site at consciousness
hackings awakened future summit we are
now going to be speaking to Yangzhou
Luke hello hi hi Alan thank you so much
for coming on I'm very excited to talk
to you he is a designer strategist at
converge also a lecturer at Stanford
designing for well-being very excited to
talk about this so who are you what do
you represent I'm an educator I'm a
facilitator I'm a designer I bring sort
of the creative integrative approach to
everything that I do and I sort of
happened upon that fairly accidentally
but you know there's no real accidents
in life right but what I do now is sort
of to teach students that particular
mindset is being very fulfilling journey
how did you accidentally yeah so I like
so many people I've gone to some Dharma
talks in my early 30s I've also done a
lot of traveling but I never saw myself
as a serious spiritual seeker that
seemed to be reserved you know to
certain folks that don't necessarily
have like a full-on career but then when
I sort of came back to the Bay Area from
Seattle for a job at LinkedIn I was
reluctant to come back to the Bay Area
and I decided I should look for a place
to meditate in order to sort of keep
myself saying
because there's just a lot of hecticness
in the barrier that sort of grounds
counter to how I'm wired and I found
this place called JUCO G which means
compassion light tempo in the Santa Cruz
Mountains and I it's sort of set in
nature and have a particular feel of
calmness and sort of a energy like a
calm spiritual energy about it so I kept
going back even though I didn't really
step my feet into the Zen dough until
sort of several you know visits later
but then the people there started saying
why don't you live here you seem like a
really good fit you seem really at home
here and I said no no no it's too far to
my workplace I have no more time for
additional things like meditation or the
responsibilities of running a Zen Center
but they kept saying it so I thought huh
like I take these sort of signals
seriously right when other people have
invitations and I thought okay maybe I
should try it because there's a month
long trial period in any way and then
why I tried it something is
instantaneously felt that time took on a
more spacious quality itself you know I
did have less free time in the evenings
especially because of the meditation and
the longer commute but it felt much more
nourishing and much more rich and so so
that I kept doing that and I basically
commuted to LinkedIn where I was working
via the mountain roads especially on a
motorcycle for a few years from the Zen
Center daily and my life sort of changed
from there and I wouldn't have known
that without actually experiencing it
without putting myself in that situation
where it was just the situation so
that's the accident but I'm very
grateful because it really changed my
set my life on the inside out okay Wow
so so you felt like a lot of what you
are was running counter to what the Bay
Area get it done yeah how he was and
then you took that invitation and you
said well you know why is it here let me
explore it a little bit more
it was a little further commute to work
but you ended up learning a lot and
enough to change the trajectory of your
life completely okay so yeah keep
teaching us about this sure I started to
feel more present I mean these are words
that I can describe later not in the not
at the time but I could feel just sort
of when my baseline being a little bit
more calm and I was more present with my
team my work I started to say things
differently you know now I can describe
a little bit more vulnerability a little
bit more experimentation putting myself
out there but at the time I just was
experimenting you know I started to use
Buddhist language things like basic
goodness and initially very tentatively
but it was clear that my team really
resonated with it right away and I
started to use more and more of it SR to
teach my team mindfulness skills you
know the basics and but also
interpersonal communication of the sort
of deeper connection right that you know
people never sort of learn right in
their education or in the beginning of
yourself being professional but it's
such a coarse skill set right for being
successful so that gave me kind of a
particular niche I work and the kind of
a brand that people started to know me
by that and started to come to me and
and then you know one thing led to
another
yeah yeah so that's how it sort of
happened so people started knowing you
as as someone that was maybe tapped in
deeper into a sense of vulnerability
compassion just you you you actually end
up could it be that you drive more
productivity by having these traits and
you should wasn't was a lot of what you
learned then through the practice of the
meditation that you were learning in
this
Santa Cruz is n Center it's called to
Cochise on such a koji okay okay
and then so then you were embodying
these and presenting them at at LinkedIn
when you're working there right okay
cool and then from there then keep us on
the journey to converge and to Stanford
how did it end up all working data class
absolutely while the other important
connections I want to bring about is my
practice in Native American spirituality
and while the main sort of signs that I
should live at your country was actually
there's a sweat lodge on site at the Zen
Center which is highly highly unusual
these coming together of spiritual
traditions but the founder of that
particular Zen Center was very welcoming
of sort of the spirit of the land and
you know for three decades or something
had the sweat lodge on site is somewhat
controversial there as well you know
their purest of the Zen tradition who
doesn't feel like these things should
mix but in any case I've had a separate
Native American practice for maybe eight
years or so prior to going to that
particular Zen Center and I learned
about the sweat lodge and wanted to
participate and I've been playing phone
tag with someone who sort of hold
ceremony there and one New Year's Eve
sort of I did a self retreat and then
the next morning New Year's Day I walk
outside of the room I was staying in and
I see this guy and I instantaneously
knew he was a person that was playing
phone tag with even though I had no idea
what he looked like I just knew and then
so moments later I was able to step from
the zendo into the sweat lodge borrowing
other people's clothes to sweat in so
that was the important sign for me that
sort of the different worlds that I
participated in actually bit all
together kind of like integration right
you're on worlds colliding which is
something I used to have a fear about so
those things those two different
practices continuing for my life a great
deal you know the Zen being more sort of
the
personal right the meditation and then
the the ceremony says Native American
spirit ceremony is more about the
interpersonal and also communication
with the divine so I started to
basically have different mindsets that I
could see how things played out and
instead of going with sort of the more
typical like rational and Silicon Valley
mindset of being rational and like
trying to decide compromises and the
best approach forward I started to have
a different mentality which is basically
the contrast between balance or
compromise and integration and I'll
describe it a little bit yes please
so balance is you know we can see the
picture of a balance and it's
essentially kind of a zero-sum game if
you want more of something there has to
be a list of something else right so
it's a particular mental model that it's
actually a game that we could no never
win especially you know in a world that
changes so fast even when people have
achieved some sort of balance
immediately like it's gone the window
because something has shifted right
their work life has shifted their family
life has shifted they need to move etc
etc we can't actually potentially if we
have a child or whatever the additional
yeah adding thing is to the equation we
do have to take time away from other
that's right that's right that's right
and so it's a particular goal that is
actually kind of a fallacy that people
talk about all the time right work-life
balance but it's actually like kind of a
mental model that is people are set up
for failure so if you love what you do
every single day yeah exactly it's not
about correct exactly exactly
whereas integration is exactly that it's
like everything we love infuses
everything else and give it a kind of a
richness and wholeness right so then
there is no longer that's like I'm not
doing enough of something there is
actually everything I do everything that
I touch has meaning and and and works
together right so yeah and the mental
picture that I
use is kind of inking water you know I
come from China where you know
calligraphy and painting etc that's sort
of part of the culture so when ink meets
the water right the pattern as in sort
of nature the fractals is different
every time
just like our life but the to quickly
become completely inseparable right and
so our practice our spiritual practice
in this example is the ink and
everything else we do our work our
family our relationships is the water
and so the spiritual life makes
everything more rich that was my
experience is it took on a different
quality I became different
I showed up different yes okay so it was
the training of the ink the training of
sexuality that makes everything that you
touch and life have meaning yeah versus
the balance and versus all the other
mental maps that we have of the way that
we engage with the world interesting and
then what are some of the best are you
then teaching some of the best practices
to develop the spirituality and the ink
right now is that kind of what you're
sure sure
yeah so I teach these kind of different
mindsets right and actually students get
it like really really quickly because
they understand like this is the only
this is not the only tool right has a
lot of limitations when we try to
rationally solve situations often it
jolly doesn't work right or it can work
for a short amount of time but it's not
really how things work out nothing works
in life by like logically really like
things are emergent right so so I teach
people basically sort of the creative
emergent ways of thinking which actually
luckily Design Thinking is very much
about that so my profession and my
spiritual practice comes together to
sort of inform my view that I can share
with students yeah and I take them
through sort of the creative process
right this is using design thinking to
bring about changes they want to see in
the world offense through prototyping an
idea could be a technology product it
could be something else but the idea is
that they can connect deeply with their
own pain
and suffering and the things that they
want to bring up out in the world
is something that the world actually
needs very much and we're not alone in
feeling that and we don't have to solve
the problem right but actually this is
material this is material for how we are
in the world and the things that we we
create is a nonlinear process but it's
it's it's meaningful so it normalizes it
I gives it kind of a positive right
understanding of the difficulty in
students lives okay all right so then we
apply design thinking strategies to a
something that we're feeling within our
what we want to maybe what we want to
update the the code of civilization with
we want to change something that's right
and then you say okay we're gonna apply
a design thing your first principles
perspective to this of how we can have a
human centric way of of changing the
world for the better and then they
either build their idea through a
technology or whatever it may be and
then that practice itself kind of builds
the ink the spirituality absolutely
ain't healing yes you this this this
process you know like most creative
people know this right like the act of
creating it from their pain and from
their deep connectedness is it self
healing I need to happen you know are
paying is is is real science it's a part
of why we're here
Wow and there could potentially be when
we decide to follow that path of okay I
have this pain I want to create with it
that we find so much meaning from that
whereas sometimes we have the pain and
we try and numb it exactly or try to
partition it you know yeah it doesn't
work it has to be integrated it has to
be accepted
and creating help from that that exactly
everything is soil yeah Wow interesting
so then where where do you now find the
most part of the of the of creating
spirituality creating Inc within the
within students that you work with is
converge also doing work outside of
students like with organizations as well
training leadership sure converges super
fascinating I think they are it's
organization that I joined fairly
recently but I think they're doing the
coolest work around basically the idea
is that in today's complex world and
there are different kinds of problems
right organizations and leaders can no
longer with their own efforts solve
these very complicated and complex
problems it had people have to work
across boundaries they have to work in
ecosystems rather than single organizes
organisms so converge uses felissa
facilitation and deep connection and and
various tools to to create those
networks that transcend single
organizations but where people are lined
sort of the deeper challenges of our
time to to bring about sort of the
emergent possibilities that we want to
bring about so I'm very happy to sort of
be coming back into the social impact
world which is something obviously I
deeply care about I think most people in
the spiritual journey are and to use all
the tools that I have to bear for people
who sort of have the inclination that
they can do something yet they don't
feel like they can tackle these huge
challenges but we we're all doing it
we're all changemakers and that's
something that gives me deep optimism is
that are these skills and these mindsets
are so easily teachable and then what
are the boundaries that were
for coming this is just like
geopolitical yeah how to work together
sure I'm just simply the idea that you
know organizations have their own sort
of identity or have their own charters
and their bottom lines so you know like
you know our paychecks right like who
are we loyal to so the idea that you
know we are whole people right we have
loyalty or obligations and
responsibilities to the organizations
that were a part of but we also have
deep responsibilities as an engaged
human being to earth to our communities
exactly yeah and now we're all leaders
in doing that so almost as though the
corporation has kind of in the bottom
line has kind of taken more of a top
priority over Oh completely
okay and that's sort of the linear
thinking that we're seeing has a very
limited use and and actually created a
lot of problems right you know in the
past century in yeah yeah okay so then
converge is helping with the training of
the leadership at organizations to
recognize these things they create
networks and facilitate those networks
and sort of give people the capability
of continuing with these networks for
action you know they work in New York
City on homelessness problem they work
in the Santa Cruz Mountains on
stewardship of the land working across
lumber companies and preservation
organizations so very conflicting values
yet it can work and that's sort of the
amazing thing about it is that when you
get people in a room and get them to
connect to each other in a deep way as
human beings their stories through their
their their journeys people work
together people are realizing that
beyond that those sort of bottom lines
that may conflict right those financial
bottom lines they have deep alignment
so we could potentially get some of the
executives of like those oil companies
and really exactly they would forfeit
some of the companies bottom lines that
they're working at absolutely absolutely
because we're all we're not there there
are no single metric right that
determines our success you know we are
we're actually all wanting multiple
bottom lines right like you said the
community the ecology and not just a
financial bottom line that's right yeah
and so then the these processes of kind
of slowing down with some of the
executives this is just there's such a
funny thought experiment for me and my
head is you know because we've been for
such a long time trying to envision what
it would be like if the you know if the
UN General Assembly was there just you
know have some more thoughts of yeah
that unity and that yeah unbounded love
and yeah compassion like what would it
yeah how would we do it how would it
change right if the oil companies were
to be like it's okay our bottom line can
take a hit we're gonna transition to
this type of stuff it's like it's it's
almost funny but it's such so needed oh
yeah so to make it actually happen yeah
you can step in and engage on absolutely
our personal sort of human level yeah I
I think like any kind of tide change
we're gonna see sinks like that sooner
than we may think right we will see you
an Assemblies and unlike the Hetzel
corporations having these conversations
you know there are people doing work on
that front some of my colleagues that
converge and there are others leadership
you know facilitators won't welcome that
offend
someone called Mark Lester he used to be
the CEO of a search inside yourself
Leadership Institute and he writes about
you know he was part of a he was invited
to facilitate at a board meeting that
was soon very much gah-ri people were
trying to get to the agenda and the
strategic strategic vision very quickly
right because obviously that's what
people's times are precious but he got
in he had people like meditate for 15
minutes which is a really long time
for people who never done that and then
he asked people the questions of you
know why are you here on this earth yes
and what are you doing to sort of bring
about your values into the world and to
have people tell stories without
interruption for five minutes about that
with the others listening on simply
holding the space yeah and he said like
in you know 20 minutes the space was
completely transformed the atmosphere
was transformed so the experience of
right being listened to a human level
yeah yeah this just the idea that listen
we only have 15 minutes we need to get
to the heart of the conversation we need
to go so fast you have to we have to go
slow to go fast yeah yeah yeah that's
there's like there's so many ideas
there's not enough time sometimes to
execute all of them right yeah
and so it's like also important to like
be vigilant with our time yeah oh yeah
to to find that way of of engaging with
people on the level that is that
meditative let's slow down I love you
you love me let's have our story time
let's enjoy that and at the same time we
or what our values why are we here on
this earth right to start a board
meeting with something like that's great
at the same time because it can catalyze
great results at the same time it's
important to be vigilant well I'm the
tensional be an intentional sure sure
okay okay alright I'm following okay so
so even just dropping in for the short
bit at the beginning can be
transformational for that necessary it's
necessary I I have that problem as well
with time I have a young child actually
under two so like there's no I have very
little time where I is that is my own
basically which is a very new part of my
life and challenge so I have you know
part of my challenge right now is like
how do I use the time that I do have how
do I use my limited energy so whilst the
practices that I'm trying to do is to
like go all the things I have done but
let also let go of the things I haven't
done that I haven't gotten to and simply
trust that whatever I do do was my time
it's fine yeah because it's it's not
possible to be like so calculated right
and so intentionally effect it was every
minute and so it part of it is just
giving us a break as well we have the
primal problem of abundance that's very
much here in Silicon Valley now right
like you know we have too many good
things to pursue opportunity abundance
yes that's right
which has opportunity cost right which
is a very difficult thing for the mind
to grok yeah and it's it's a it can be a
crazy making to try to like weigh all
those things but that's a balanced
mindset right it's like we cannot
logically weigh everything that we could
do and what opportunity might take and
what cost it might have et cetera so we
can only like yeah so one of the things
I try to do is like over time I actually
realize I can trust my actions and not
spend too much cycles like trying to
weigh things and I just whatever I do
whatever I vote for with my feet it's
funny there's where there's wisdom in my
action
yeah yeah this so all the variables of
all the ideas that we get an allocate
time to all the people of the and
running the opportunity cost
calculations and measurements and all
the stuff yeah it's also just having
some sort of a future authoring like
some something that we want to achieve
in this long term in knowing our short
summer trip stuffs but also being cool
with where we move ourselves moment to
moment getting there absolutely so
there's so many possible ways - yeah
okay yeah and hold hold
whatever this bring to a hold slightly
yeah yeah okay I want to I want to
understand is that then the the process
for designing for well-being is this
process I would say yeah mm-hmm
were overly obsessed with the
calculating opportunity costs mm-hmm
yeah I mean we put students into teams
so the idea of their original visions
may very well change with the influence
of their other people right and the
prototyping process on feedback and so
on so we really try to teach your
students to understand the emergence and
to embrace that right yeah because
future is highly emergent yeah well the
other well the things I like to say is
what could happen is much bigger and
much more magical than what you think
you want
whoa
the future is much more bigger and
magical than what we think we want if we
look back in our own lives I have that
experience right what had happened is
actually much bigger and more magical
than what I thought I wanted like my
life now is way more expensive and
magical than what I could have thought
10 or 20 years ago right so I'm casing
point of that emergent possibility and I
think for today's young people it's even
more so because the future is coming
very quickly yeah yeah you know very
rich way okay so millennial and Gen Z
huge part of the exponential technology
era pushing forth rapid changes that are
happening in our world and and so the
sort of it's sort of the the for not the
phenomenons that we may experience of
stress or anxiety or overwhelming
feeling of all the different
opportunities of social and ideas to
pursue and all that stuff to kind of
become one with all of that and just be
guided in its kind of surrender to the
direction that our divine path will end
up taking mm-hmm sure I love that and at
the same time I realized that like is it
really like surrendering to me wanting
to watch Game of Thrones or is it
surrendering to me wanting to not do
that and edit the footage it's right
you know what I mean I mean what do you
do with their thoughts like that hmm
the first thought that comes is I think
people do need the pleasure in their
lives a mind be game of throne it might
be video games you know it might be
dating and that's a natural part of
human desire that is actually really
important because it nourishes all of us
and we if we feel like the sort of the
of a void or emptyness we would always
want to fill it with something but when
we have deep pleasure then that cup is
filled and then the rest of the
decision-making process become much
easier because you're not from acting
from a place of deficit so so it could
be that the cup could be filled though
with either the game of throne or
videogamer dating or could be filled
with doing something like absolutely
losing yeah content yeah and so okay so
then maybe then one of the things is to
kind of have a experience different
items at the buffet to see what yes of
the cup yes that's right that's right
and allowing oneself to make mistakes in
there because we all know well know when
something's not fulfilling say something
at the buffet absolutely you say that
wasn't as fulfilling for my compass when
I do this exactly any for where if we
have some level of awareness then I
think actually we're all very sensitive
to how something can be like hollow
pressure pleasure and when something is
real pleasure hollow pleasure versus
real pleasure I like that yeah right
yeah cuz there's you know there's a lot
of stress in life and we want to escape
like that's human nature but I think you
know like FOMO and sort of the
strategies to you know act on that so
you know like basically comparison with
other people can take up a lot of time
I can quickly feel not really satisfying
like it may like give you a little bit
of a hit right but I think I think you
know like people eventually have enough
experiences when things is like too
quick of a hit right with no longer
sustained you're feeling Wow and but you
know it takes honesty and hopefully good
friends around you like not give you the
sort of the negative reinforcement right
yeah yeah so it's almost as though we
have the best innate ability to parse
the buffet of options to find what is
most fulfilling for us occasionally we
can be consuming something that is
hollowly fulfilling and we need the
right environment of parents community
friends etc to be like you know try this
see what you think of this and then
maybe you find more fulfillment to that
I feel like one of the things that's
coming up more frequently is that the
whole movement towards social emotional
mental physical spiritual well-being
right because you are designing for
well-being so the whole movement in that
direction is fascinating and I think
it's really providing some nutrition for
people fulfillment simultaneously I find
myself at times potentially finding a
lot of fulfillment in just being alone
mm-hmm as well yeah I have so many ideas
I just want to like be able to try and
synthesize right oh yeah package it
opens a multimedia goodness and so yeah
so yeah so then there's these like
there's this sometimes someone will say
like we should be such a recluse you
should or whatever and so it's almost as
though do we how well do we know
ourselves know thyself that'd be most
important
in fulfillment okay yeah yeah and
aloneness is really unnecessary practice
I think for everybody even for the more
social socially oriented people I think
someone said that solitude is only as
good as the compassionate grades and I
have the experience in myself and I can
see it in other people also that when
they spend time alone they actually feel
more connected afterwards because we
have become more connected to ourselves
I mean that process become more generous
more loving so give yourself that I love
that the the the the such the rapid pace
of just attaching ourselves to this
whenever we feel that the time of
boredom are aloneness aloneness it was
is bad in so many ways because we don't
yeah tap deeper in and then be able to
tap deeper to the communities and being
this has been such an interesting
conversation with you you're yeah you're
doing some powerful conversations with
me and inspiration hopefully for others
and the work at converging and that
Stanford is good work thank you thanks
for this time on the show and talking to
us a pleasure
we appreciate quick question I want to
ask you do you think we're in a
simulation oh I would say the main
answer is no this is real our bodies are
real and we how we experience our
reality however is completely up to our
internal States up to these processes
and sort of the metaphysical you know
combinations of how things are which are
kind of hard to describe
but no I think I think we're real and
I'm grateful for that and then what do
you thinks the most beautiful thing in
the world I want to say right now since
I have a little one is sort of the love
of of young children their love is so
completely pure and it's heartbreaking
but we are all that right we're all
young children we
and love that and if we can bring about
that you know where we'll all be much
closer to this closer to our house where
can people find you on the Internet is
kind of what's converges URL converge
doesn't converge dotnet is the URL the
link is in the bio for that also is
LinkedIn yeah it was a good place okay
yeah
and Ning djalu's on on LinkedIn as well
the link is below and huge thank you
everyone for tuning in we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode go and talk to more
people your friends your family people
on social media your co-workers about
what it's like to piece together these
next conversations for well being and
designing for well being around our
world and also check out the links below
to consciousness hacking into simulation
support organizations to entrepreneurs
and the artists around the world that
you believe in and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in to we will see you soon thank
you